bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir vous le reconnaissez David fonkinos
vient nous parler de son dernier livre
bonsoironsoir merci d'être notre grand
témoin ce soir on va parler de la vie
heureuse chez galima roman tendre et
surprenant sur la deuxème chance un
homme assiste à ses propres funéraill
pour mieux se réinventer ça se passe
entre la Corée du Sud et les milieux
politiques parisien on va en parler
c'est drôle c'est enlevé et comme
souvent ça raconte l'époque comme dans
beaucoup de vos livres on en parle tous
les deux tout à l'heure dans la deuxème
partie notre grand débat ce soir
jusqu'où ira la grogne des agriculteurs
le mouvement de blocage s'étend la crise
s'installe et la pression monte sur le
gouvernement au vert d'ose de normes
revenu de misère comment répondre au
ralbol des paysans nous en débattons
dans un instant avec mes invités enfin
nos affanchi ce soir regard sur l'Europe
Richard verli le billet philo
Pierre-Henri tavoyot et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr elles amondin Gava
voilà pour le sommaire on y va David
fkino avec plaisir ça vous regarde top
générique
[Musique]
elle monte elle monte la colère des
agriculteurs le mouvement de blocage
s'étend aujourd'hui à toute la France et
bien malin celui qui sait combien de
temps il va durée c'est la première
crise que doit affronter Gabriel Atal à
Matignon le Premier ministre doit faire
des annonces dans les jours qui viennent
mais comment répondre à une grogne
hétérogène aux interlocuteurs multiples
bonsoir Louis Margerite bonsoir
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député renaissance de sonellois votre
département est touché par les blocages
vous avez rencontré je crois les
agriculteurs mobilisés vous nous direz
ce que vous comprenez ce que vous sentez
remontter du du terrain bonsoir Grégoire
de fournass bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député rassemblement national
de Gironde exploitant agricole de
profession bonsoir Emmanuel vanandam
bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau vous êtes agriculteur bio sur le
plateau de sacclet où vous produisez du
blé et du pain vous m'arrêtez si je me
trompe oui c'est ça vous êtes membre de
la confédération paysane qui a été reçu
avec d'autres syndicats à Matignon enfin
bonsoir Emmanuel Ducro bonsoir grand
plaisir de vous retrouver ancienne
chroniqueuse dans cette émission et bien
sûr journaliste à l'opinion spécialiste
des questions agricoles vous suivez de
depuis le début ce ce mouvement
l'opinion qui s'interroge en une
aujourd'hui sur la nature de ce
mouvement les gilets verts sont-ils les
nouveaux gilets jaunes David fonkenos
n'hésitez pas même à interroger nos
invités ça n'est pas vos sujet mais on
sait que le monde Agricol intéresse les
écrivains les réalisateurs donc
sentez-vous livre quand vous voulez
avant de vous donner la parole on va
planter un petit peu le le décor le
point sur les blocages les
revendications les réactions politiques
c'est dans le recap de Valérie Brochard
qu'on accueille tout de suite
et bonsoir bonsoir cher Valérie bonsoir
Meren bonsoir à toutes et à tous on peut
parler de crise oui c'est la crise
Myriam la crise du monde agricole des
Benes de fumiers devant l'Office de la
biodiversité du Loir et Cher des
tracteurs en plein milieu d'une quatre
voie dans les Côtes d'Armor des meules
de foin en travers de la route en
Gironde les agriculteurs sont en colère
et menacent très sérieusement d'aller
porter leur revendication jusqu'à la
capitale écoutez bouge très peu je pense
qu'au salon plus après les Jos il y aura
des tracteurs sur le sur les chisés et
là là ce sera trop tard parce que une
fois qu'on est parti on s'arrête plus
alors tout a commencé dans le Tarne
rappelez-vous à l'automne dernier des
éleveurs des céréaliers retournaient les
panneaux des villes pour symboliser leur
sentiment à l'impression de marcher sur
la tête de se tuer à la tâche pour rien
d'appliquer des normes qu'on demande pas
aux autres pays européens aujourd'hui
myiam 85 départements sont concernés et
la gronde sera rapproche dangereusement
de Paris regardez cette carte les
agriculteurs bloquent les autoroutes
entre poau et Bayon autour de Lyon entre
Valence et Grenoble sur la rocade
d'Orléan tout autour de Strasbourg il y
a en ce moment même des moissonneuses
batteuses qui sont déployé aux abords de
nombreuses routes en Bretagne bref vous
l'avez compris la mobilisation est
générale très suivie à la hauteur du
ralbol ressenti comme nous l'explique
cette agricultrice les normes les
dossiers qu'on doit faire pour avoir le
droit de
travailler les choses qu'on nous promet
et
que jamais on nous donne et puis voilà
on travaille toute l'année très peu
d'entre nous on vivent bien ou même en
vivent tout quoi voilà on a tous des
familles à nourrir et que personne ne
veut nous rémunérer pour le travail
qu'on fait alors que on nourrit tout le
monde très concrètement Miriam
aujourd'hui en France une éleveuse ou un
maréché doit respecter des règles
strictes dépendage et donc dépend endre
de la pluie et du vent planter des ha
pour soutenir la biodiversité mais
attention interdiction de les tailler de
les entretenir avant le 15 août payer la
hausse des taxes sur le gazol routier
vous savez c'est l'essence qui fait
avancer les tracteurs et puis remplir
les déclarations pour la pack les
cahiers phytosanitaires les carnets
d'élevage et vous savez quoi ceci n'est
qu'une toute petite partie de la longue
liste des règles à respecter bien tout
simplement pour exercer son métier alors
le président de la République qui voit
les tracteurs se rapprocher de l'Élysée
entend comprend et c'est même fendu d'un
tweet adressé aux agriculteurs j'ai
demandé au gouvernement d'être
pleinement mobilisé pour apporter des
solutions concrètes aux difficultés que
vous rencontrez aussitôt tweeté aussitôt
fait le premier ministre a donc promis
hier dans l'hémicycle annoncer des
initiatives en fin de semaine dans
l'entourage de Gabriel hatal on annonce
également qu'une partie de sa
déclaration de politique générale sera
consacrée au malais paysan mais mais
vous le savez myiam et vous tous sur ce
plateau cette réponse elle est
éminemment politique personne ne veut
lâcher les agriculteurs tout le monde
veut les récupérer c'est pourquoi
Gabriel hatal prévient aussi le monde
agricole pardon de ne pas succomper aux
sirènes du rassemblement national on
l'écoute parler avec nos agriculteurs
c'est évidemment parler avec des femmes
des hommes qui sont évidemment dans
l'angoisse et je vais y revenir mais
c'est aussi parler avec des femmes et
des hommes lucides lucide sur
l'importance de l'Union européenne et ça
a été redit par le ministre Marc fenau
pour les aides de la pâac pour nos
capacités d'export et donc je le dis il
y a aussi une lucidité face à ceux qui
butinent de colère en colère en donnant
le sentiment qu'on pourrait sortir de
l'Union européenne voilà voilà pour la
tacle en règle contre le rassemblement
national ici en France et pendant ce
temps-là à Bruxelles c'est une autre
figure de l'extrême droite qui s'est
emparée du sujet vous avez raison
mobilisez-vous allez sur le terrain euh
euh bloquez faites entendre votre voix
parce que malheureusement en France et
j'ai le sentiment en Europe c'est le
seul moyen d'être entendu alors on
comprend la manœuvre politique mais
l'urgence c'est d'éviter le blocage
total du pays alors que au moment même
où on se parle myiam les grilles de la
préfecture d'agin sont en ce moment en
flamme je vous laisse sur cette la
tension monte à jein notamment et
peut-être un début de radicalisation de
de ce mouvement je vous donne la parole
dans un instant mais on voulait prendre
la température ce soir alors on se parle
puisque il y a des nuits de blocage dans
dans le pays on va rejoindre Franck
Sander bonsoir vous êtes agriculteur et
vis président de la FNSEA qui est
solidaire du mouvement vous êtes
j'espère avec nous merci d'être re là
cette nuit sur l'un des points de
blocage sur l'autoroute à l'entrée de
Strasbourg alors décrivez-nous tout
simplement ce qui se passe autour de
vous autour de ce barrage et la
détermination sur le terrain ben écoutez
bonsoir à tous Alors nous la
mobilisation elle a commencé cet
après-midi ou même ce matin pour les
plus éloignés c'est plus de 400
tracteurs qui se rassemblent aujourd'hui
au centre de Strasbourg pour bah tout
simplement bloquer l'autoroute he c'est
comme vous avez dit on est parti de
mouvements qui étit censé être comment
dire censé pouvoir faire évoluer les
choses avec des panneaux à l'envers on
marche sur la tête et cetera et on voit
bien que rien a bouger et donc le
durcissement du mouvement effectivement
il est en route et d'ailleurs notre
mobilisation elle va largement au-delà
de nos attentes et donc il y a un moment
pour revendiquer c'est vrai mais sur
place aussi les agriculteurs nous nous
sommes organisés pour passer un moment
de convivialité entre nous c'est-à-dire
voilà de pouvoir se restaurer échanger
partager nos problèmes pour éviter de se
retrouver seul de nos fermes et donc oui
c'est le mouvement il est très très
suivi et je ne sais pas si on lèvera le
camp demain les agriculteurs se sont
mobilisés une agricultrice encore à
l'instant me disait mon frère est parti
manifester j'ai demandé à prendre un
tracteur sur la ferme je l'ai accompagné
on est là deux c'est le moment où j'ai
jamais on en a vraiment besoin ouais
autre question on comprend que vous
appelez à amplifier le mouvement mais
pas à bloquer forcément le pays alors
que d'autres parlent même de de faire
venir les les tracteurs jusqu'à Paris il
y a deux grandes revendication pour les
résumer simplement les revenus et les
normes vous diriez ça aussi
ben la première des choses déjà c'est
qu'aujourd'hui l'agriculteur travaille
beaucoup beaucoup d'heur et gagne pas
beaucoup et donc la première des choses
c'est déjà reconnaître le bienfait de
nourrir les hommes ça c'est la première
des choses et bien évidemment le revenu
est quelque chose d'important mais pour
avoir du revenu il faut simplifier des
choses trop de contraintte administrativ
je le rappelle on est là pour produire
on est là pour être dans nos champs on
est là pour être dans les étables auprès
des vaches et cetera auprès de nos
animaux mais on n'est surtout pas là
pour être surtransposé et donc
aujourd'hui les surtransposation
transposition vis-à-vis l'Union
européenne c'est quelque chose qui est
aujourd'hui inacceptable surtout que le
Président de la République s'est engagé
à ce qu'il y en est pas ça n'est pas le
cas les normes aujourd'hui il y en a
beaucoup trop dans nos exploitations
agricoles et donc c'est un tout qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la France régresse la
France historiquement puissance agricole
grande puissance aujourd'hui a perdu
plus de 20 % de sa production en général
et tout ça c'est l'importation qui prend
le relais et surtout l'importation avec
des produits dont on ne veut absolument
pas les moyens et les méthodes avec
lesqueles ça a été produit merci
beaucoup franander vous voulez prendre
le pou comme ça sur le terrain à
l'entrée de de Strasbourg il y a de la
peur il y a de la colère c'est très
clair Emmanuel Ducro vous vous
connaissez bien les sujets agricoles
vous avez beaucoup d'interlocuteurs dans
ce monde-là qu'est-ce qui se passe quel
mot vous mîriez de quoi est-ce le nom ce
mouvement que personne n'a vu venir et à
part l'Europe il y a l'Allemagne mais là
d'un coup tout remonte alors je suis pas
d'accord pour dire qu'on l'a pas vu
venir on l'a vu venir de très très très
très loin ce qu'on voit là c'est la
dernière goutte d'eau d'un vase qui
déborde le vase il s'est rempli il s'est
rempli au fil du temps il s'est rempli
AC tout ce qu'on vient d'entendre hein
la règle la norme le tracat
administratif les les agriculteurs qui
disent qu'il passent une journée de leur
vie chaque semaine à remplir des
dossiers pour la pâac pour les aides
pour pour des quantités de choses pour
des déclarations de de on va venir
d'ailleurs dans le détail avec un sujet
il y a le côté PaaS mais il y a aussi
les normes Environnmental c'est alors
les normes environment c'est pas les
normes environnementales qui pose
problème c'est la contraintte autour des
normes environnementales c'est c'est
c'est enfin vraiment je pense qu'il faut
pas il faut pas confondre les deux le le
souci de l'environnement il est là chez
les agriculteurs il voit bien que le le
changement climatique est là c'est la
manière dont c'est dont c'est dont c'est
ça comment dire la contrainte que ça
génère et le sentiment punitif que ça
génère et puis il y a une troisième
chose qui je pense est fondamentale
c'est le besoin de dignité des
agriculteurs français la reconnaissance
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont quand même la le
sentiment de faire une tâche qu'on leur
a demandé de faire dans laa près-gerre
la France au sortir de la guerre n'était
pas indépendante dans sa façon de se
nourrir cette C indépendance cette
souveraineté alimentaire c'est une
construction ce sont des années
d'investissement pour 1 € de nourriture
qu'on produit aujourd'hui on a 7 €
d'investissement des générations
précédentes en savoir-faire en terre en
matériel donc donc en fait ils ont fait
ce travail qu'on leur a demandé de faire
que le ministre de l'Agriculture pisané
a demandé de faire on a conquis une
souveraineté alimentaire une puissance
agricole et aujourd'hui non seulement
elle est menacée par des importations
qui ne sont pas à nos normes mais ce qui
est quand même assez scandaleux elle est
menacée aussi par le reproche qu'on leur
fait de bousiller l'environnement alors
qu'ils ont quand même énormément évolué
de bousiller la santé des gens ce qui
enfin ce qui quand même un peu on les
culpabilise c'est ça on les
culpabilise on les réprouve on les
méprise et on leur explique en
permanence comment ils doivent
travailler donc si vous voulez tout ça
ça voilà c'est ces petites gouttes d'eau
qui se sont çaêre compliqué he
politiquement oui de répondre à tout ça
quand c'est r si l dire un dernier mot
on a vu des colères locales ça a
commencé dans le sud-ouest de la France
où il y a une maladie qui frappe les
vaches une maladie dit qu'il les
affaibli il y a eu la grippe du canard
avant donc ça ça a commencé là chaque
région a ses propres revendications et
puis on a la grande revendication du
mépris de l'écrasement en fait de
l'écrasement le paysan il est en bout de
chaîne de la norme et il est écrasé et
les salaires aussi hein parce que quand
on regarde les revenus la rémunération
18 % des agriculteurs sont au dessous du
seuil de pauvreté hein à000 1080 € donc
ça fait beaucoup je je vais vers le le
syndicaliste que vous êtes Emmanuel
Vandam c'est vrai que la Confédération
pays elle a été reçue mais elle est pas
à l'initiative directement puisque au
fond c'est un mouvement un peu qui qui
surgit on parle de la Coordination
Rurale on découvre un peu les choses
vous vous retrouvez quand même dans ce
ralbol vous êtes solidaire ah ben c'est
une évidence qu'on est solidaire de des
éleveurs par exemple qui travaillent 16
heures par jour et puis qui vivent pas
de leur métier enfin qui ici sur ce
plateau serait d'accord pour travailler
14 he par jour et gagner à peine 800 €
par mois mais ça gêne personne au niau
au gouvernemental puisque on continue
dans ce dans ce système les maréchés qui
quand ils font des légumes ils arrivent
toujours plus cher que les légumes qu'on
importe de de Sicile par exemple ou
d'Espagne qui sont fabriqués par des
gens qui sont bien souvent des immigrés
qu'on ne paye pas qu'on ne loge à peine
tout ça c'est accepté c'est accepté par
notre société et du coup oui évidemment
évidemment il y a donc le malaise est
très profond pour vous même s'il y a pas
une étincelle en Allemagne c'est
vraiment
le prix du carburant là il y a un
ensemble de choses moi je vais vous dire
c'est pas le prix du carburant c'est oui
comme vous dites c'est une étincelle
mais le feu le feu qui dure depuis 20
ans c'est que on ne paye pas les denrées
alimentaires en France au prix qu'ell
valent c'est quand même hallucinant
essayez d'aller acheter je sais pas
n'importe quel smartphone à la moitié du
prix qui est proposé vous l'aurez pas
mais en France quelle que soit
l'exploitation dans laquelle un
agriculteur peut travailler à l'issue la
vente de son produit elle ne le paye pas
je dire c'est quand même fou il y a il y
a 15 ans il y a eu un grand mouvement
vers la vers le vers la conversion à
l'agriculture biologique avec l'État qui
était derrière 15 ans après le blé bio
vaut quasiment moins cher que le blé
conventionnel et que fait le
gouvernement actuel rien il a soutenu
énormément la haute valeur
environnementale ou la Haute Qualité
Environnementale donc les gens sont dit
bah oui il faut aller sur ce créneau là
parce que apparemment c'est mieux
respecter la nature et cetera c'est
absolument faux sur ces les critères
pour faire ça c'est juste de mettre une
ea c'est juste de mettre un peu de
jacher mais en aucun cas de diminuer les
pesticides donc enfin c'est c'est on
tourne complètement donc tous les gens
qui ont investi sur l'agriculture bio
tous ces gens qui sont allés sur ce
créneau là pas pour faire de l'argent
parce qu'ils croyaient vraiment à quel à
à un respect de la nature aujourd'hui il
y en a qui se déconvertissent pour aller
vers la culture conventionnelle enfin
c'est tourne tour quoi aujourd'hui quels
que soient les syndicats la
confédérationisane est engagée dans les
question écologique soutient le
mouvement et c'est c'est c'est notable
vous Margerite c'est compliqué là pour
vous on voit que la tension monte on a
vu les images à à jein et on a
l'impression que vous vous retardez un
peu les les réponses l'idée c'est quoi
il faut laisser passer laisser
s'exprimer cette colère c'est ça la
stratégie d'abord évidemment c'est un CR
de détresse c'est un crtresse qui vient
du cœur et c'est pas des revendications
qui viennent d'aujourd'hui à l'évidence
alors ça veut pas dire qu'on a rien fait
depuis mais à l'évidence on n pas fait
assez et pass ass de passz de façon
puissante alors on est il faut quand
même quelques jours pour que au plus au
plus haut au plus haut niveau de l'État
les choses soient dites soient exprimées
effectivement il faut qu'il y a une
réponse rapide Premier ministre parle de
quelques jours donc je pense qu'on on
est sur ce calendrier là pourquoi
précisément la réponse ça peut être
française je dis parce qu'il y a des
leviers ça décide en Europe alors il y a
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de choses il y
a évidemment d'abord la stricte et et
peut-être plus dur éventuellement
application des Galim et des Galim 2
parce que ce qu'on a voulu faire alors
la loi et Galim précisé pour ce qui qui
dans la précédente mandature a permis de
garantir un prix au producteur parce que
il faut juste expliquer une chose très
simple on ne peut pas à la fois avoir un
prix bas pour le consommateur voir un
prix qui diminue et un prix qui
effectivement doit être celui qui doit
correspondre au prix de revient au cû de
revien là dans ce contexte d'inflation
par exemple est-ce que les par exemple
les producteurs de lait on ont profité
d'une certaine façon de la hausse des
prix ou ça marche pas- ass un peu mais
pas assez et ça dépend en plus parce que
certains sont en coopératif ça dépend
aussi leur F mais en tout cas il faut il
faut regarder dans le détail mais un peu
mais pas assez donc donc donc c'est ça
c'est là on a une difficulté est-ce que
est-ce que disent il y a beaucoup de
revendications vous l'avez dit mais si
on on reste sur le revenu parce que ça
c'est quand même essentiel 18 % des
agriculteur 1/ 5 vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté 1083 € par mois pour un
agriculteur qui bosse parfois 70 he par
semaine vous avez fait bien de la le
rappeler c'est un revenu qui a chuté de
40 % en 30 ans vous répondez la loi é
Galim il faut faire respecter mieux la
loi davantage qui quit quit aller plus
loin moi je suis je suisouvert cette
question mais mais ce qui ce qui et par
contre ce qui rend j'allais dire dingue
n nos éleveurs et a raison et nos
agriculteurs c'est lorsqu'il voi que sur
les étales de de grande surface il y en
a dans ma circonscription je suisch en
surs à monsolmine on a un produit ça
peut être un fruit ça peut être parfois
de la viande qui est produit qui est à 1
,10 par exemple le kilo de pomme alors
que à 10 ou 15 km de de de de cette
grande surface on a le prix à 2 2 € 2,50
€ et ça c'est terrible et là-dessus il
faut qu'on travaille qu'on ait des
réponses précises et fortes rapidement
alors Grégoire de fournass qu'est-ce que
propose le rassemblement sal sur les
revenus les revenus des producteurs
est-ce que c'est une question tout
simplement d'application de la loi de
mettre la pression sur la grande
distribution sur les industriels c'est
juste ça alors tout d'abord moi je peux
pas laisser monsieur Marguerite nous
dire qu'ils n'ont pas assez fait en la
vraie question qu'il faudrait se poser
c'est le mal qu'ils ont fait parce que
au centre des des revendications des
agriculteurs vous avez quand même la
question des traités de libre échange
que vous députés européens ont voté au
Parlement européen et tout récemment
CELI on parler de des questions
européennes mais moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire en
France tout de suite est-ce que il faut
une nouvelle loi est-ce qu'il faut mieux
faire appliquer la loi si vous étiez aux
affaires en France qu'est-ce que vous
proposeriez sur le revenu sur question
sur sur sur la question des lois Galim
le fond du problème c'est que ces lois
ne sont pas appliquées voilà Monsieur le
Maire vient de nous annoncer qu'il
allait envoyer sans inspecteur pour
vérifier si les lois et Galim étent
bienqu appliqué la question qu'on se
pose c'est pourquoi ces inspecteurs
n'ont pas été envoyés plus tôt pour
vérifier que les lois appliqu
consiste à faire voter des LO on a éalim
1 éalim 2 éalim mais derrière il y a
aucun suivi de ces lois moi j'ai
moi-même été au tribunal de commerce
avec un viticulteur de ma
circonscription qui qui qui a mis deux
négociants au tribunal sur la base de la
loialim 1 il y avait la possibilité que
le ministère de l'économie se présente
avec ce véticulteur pour le soutenir et
demander une amende auprès de ses
négociants le ministère de l'économie
était absent absent du du tribunal parce
que les lois égalim ne sont pas suivies
sérieusement donc coup de pression
supplémentaire sur la grande
distribution sur les marges et les
contrôles là vous êtes d'accord c'est
c'est vrai il faut le souligner Emmanuel
duc sur les sur les revenus il y a les
moyens de la faire respecter quand on
regarde le prix du lait il coûte 450 480
€ à produire il est payé 400 c'est hors
la loi le problème le problème c'est que
toute cette surnormation de la relation
commerciale qui dure depuis 30 ans un
jour j'ai fait le décompte de toutes les
lois qui ont été créées pour enc ad les
relations de la grande distribution avec
ses fournisseurs c'est du délire
c'est-à-dire que juste le fait qu'on
contractualise chaque année avec dans
des dates encadrées ça n'existe qu'en
France cette chosel elle est génératrice
de tension de frustration
d'inadaptation parce que on voit bien
que on est en train de courir après
l'inflation on a couru dans un sens
quand elle était en train de monter là
elle reflu on recourt dans l'autre sens
enfin je veux dire ce truc là n'a pas de
sens faut des négociations continues
permanent mais oui parce que là on ne
suit pas les les cours il y a des cours
mondiaux pour certaines choses on ne les
suit pas on les suit avec retard ça fait
des trous de trésorerie enfin ce truc
est insensé quand même on encadre
quelque chose qui ne devrait pas
forcément être encadré la relation comme
on a plus on a essayé de protéger le
monde agricole plus on l'a piégé dans
des indices de construction des prix qui
sont incompréhensibles c'est très très
compliqué il y a un modèle à suivre à
l'étranger j'ai pas de solution j'ai pas
de solution parfaite mais à un moment il
faut peut-être qu'on se pose la question
de savoir si on doit régler par la loi
les erreurs de la loi vous voyez enfin
c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est absurde c'est vraiment absurde on
en rajoute des couches sans déconstruire
ce qu'il y a eu avant enfin c'est
vraiment c'est c'est dément alors pour
le revenu oui il y a des vraies
questions on a des indices de
construction des prix mais là on est
clairement dans une situation qui peut
pas se régler on a un ministre de
l'économie qui a un bout dit c'est fini
l'inflation alimentaire elle a augmenté
de 20 % en 2 ans c'est terminé et puis à
l'autre bout de la chaîne on dit bah les
producteurs disent bah oui mais nous on
continue à payer l'électricité plus cher
et puis vous avez demandé est-ce qu'on
renchérisse les salaires ce qui était
très légitime pour tout le monde mais
les salaires de de nos de nos employés
aussi se sont renchéris enfin donc il se
retrouvent avec des charges qui
augmentent et à l'autre bout de la
chaîne on dit au consommateur c'est pas
vous qui Pirez je pense qu'en fait il
faut aussi qu'on admette que
collectivement on a tous accepté de
payer l'alimentation trop peu cher par
rapport à ce qu'elle par rapport à sa
valeur ce c'est en fait on refuse de
payer la valeur du travail des il va
falloir accepter de payer plus cher des
produit agricoles Françis de la
nourriture non vous dites non moi je
suis en désaccord avec cette analyse si
vous voulez que que l'alimentation coûte
moins cher pour les ménages aujourd'hui
Queen 1950 quand on voit tous les
progrès technologiques qu'on fait
l'agriculture l'industrie même la
distribution c'est normal que
l'alimentation coûte moins cher mais le
problème les carences des lois é Galim
les carences des lois é Galim c'est
qu'elle refuseent de s'attaquer aux
marges des intermédiaires en
l'occurrence de la grande distribution
et de certains certains gros gros
industriel et là pour une fois quel que
soit le bord politique tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'il faut réduire
ses mar jeis mettre plus de pression
changer de méthode on parle des normes
on va parler des normes j'aurais bien
répondu làdessus parcerais qu'on avance
parement simplement juste pour rappel
que le rassembl national dans la
précédenteement nature n'a pas voté les
loisalim égalim 1alim 2 ça c'est le
premier élément non mais juste j'ai dis
pas que c'est parfait était si députés
et Mar Leen expqué que
c déjà 2017 elle le dit pratiquement
2022 mais dans les mêmes phrases qu il
faut baisser le prix au consommateur
augmenter le prix au producteurs mais ça
c'est tout alors peut-être que vous
serez d'accord sur la bureaucratie sur
la PAP je reprends l'expression
d'Emmanuel Ducro dans l'opinion c'est
Kafka sur un tracteur explication Marco
Pomier on nous impose toujours plus de
normes mais comment faire pour appliquer
ces normes chaque matin on est prêt à se
lever pour faire comme il faut notre
travail mais aujourd'hui on a une
surcharge de administrative qui fait que
ce travail là est il a perdu de son sens
sur les barrages routiers partout en
France à chaque fois la même
exaspération
dans le viseur des agriculteurs
notamment l'inflation des normes ici en
charante cet agriculteur devait semer du
blé en décembre après le maïs l'année
dernière c'est une réglementation
européenne qui lui impose cette rotation
des cultures mais la météo de ces
derniers mois en a décidé autrement la
terre c'est comme de la pâte à modeler
et implanter de la céréal dans cette
dans ces conditions on sait qu'elle va
pas lever jeanbernard sal ne pourra pas
cultiver le blé en temps et en he
s'expliquer c'est un document qu'on a à
remplir où il faut que je stipule le
numéro de la parcelle sa surface ce que
j'avais prévu d'y mettre et ce que je
vais y mettre et en plus des photos
géolocalisées des démarches fastidieuses
mais obligatoires pour cet agriculteur
au risque de perdre une partie des aides
européennes soit 60000 € chaque année
c'est pas pour ça que je fais ce métier
je fais ce métier parce que je veux
produire et je veux vivre de du prix de
mes produits overdose de norme aussi
pour cet éleveur de port en Bretagne
pour le confort des bêtes Laurent d'tois
a installé un méthaniseur pour le
chauffage un bâtiment refait à neuf coût
de l'investissement 4 millions d'euros
mais cet agriculteur dénonce des délais
trop longs alourdis par une
administration trop tatillonne sur le
point de vue agro-environnemental sur le
point de vue comment bien-être animal et
plein de choses il faut aujourd'hui à
peu près 3 ans pour que votre bâtiment
voit le jour selon une enquête de l'IREF
un agriculteur français passe en moyenne
9h par semaine à remplir des formulaires
Emmanuel Ducron on regardeant le
reportage vous disiez un moment précis
d'un agriculteur qui explique la balange
de NME ça c'est sidérant alors je vous
je vais essayer d'expliquer parce que
c'est c'est faut fa un peu s'accrocher
quand on fait une moisson de blé en août
corrigez-moi si je me trompe hein quand
on fait une moisson de blé en août on
n'est pas supposé laisser la terre toute
nue derrière et c'est très bien parce
que on capte du carbone avec un couvert
végétal on n'est pas obligé de sommer ce
couvert végétal si on va utiliser de
nouveau la parcelle à l'automne pour
faire autre chose en revanche si on
attend un peu plus longtemps on laisse
un couvert végétal cet agriculteur il a
fait sa moisson il n'a pas mis de
couvert végétal parce qu'il avait
l'intention de se mettre du blé un petit
peu plus tard et là sa terre est
tellement détrempée qu'il ne peut pas se
Messon blé donc l'administration lui
demande pourquoi il n'a pas de couvert
végétal sur cette terre et là il dit bah
je devais semer là je peux pas c'est
détrempé et on lui dit ah bah oui mais
on va te sanctionner parce que tu n'as
pas pas planter ton couvert végétal au
mois d'août donc en fait il est supposé
avoir une boule de cristal pour savoir
qu'il n'a pas pu planter son blé en
octobre ou en novembre et qu'il aurait
dû prévoir en a qu'il lui fallait un
couvert végétal mais ça va au-delà de ça
ça et il est en infraction il doit
remplir un document géolocalisé sa
parcelle avec un téléphone pour
confirmer que les satellites qui passent
adessus de sa ferme ont bien compris le
message Emmanuel Vandame vous opinez
fait moi j'ai refusé j'ai refusé j'ai on
nous demandait d'envoyer des photos
géolocalisées des parcelles qu'on avait
pasmé et de surtout d'expliquer pourquoi
on lesisait on les avait passemés vous
avez les pieds dans l'eau non mais en
fait c'est c'est juste au mois de
novembre pour ceux qui sont pas du
métier il s'en rappellent peut-être pas
mais il est tombé il y a eu une
pluviométrie énorme énorme énorme énorme
et on n' pas pu tout semer on n pas pu
tout emblaver ce qu'on devait faire et
partout en France et du coup nous nous
c'est le désarois parce que faire une
rotation une succession parcellaire
surtout en agriculture bio c'est
extrêmement compliqué et quand on ne
peut pas la mettre en place il faut
qu'on trouve des solutions moi j'ai
toujours pas les solution pour les
parcelles qui sont passmé et on reçoit
un courrier de l'administration qui nous
demande de faire des photos géolocalisé
des parcelles de donner les relevés
plométrique si on en a sur la ferme ou
sinon c'est quand même mieux des
stations météo enregistrées j'ai refusé
j'ai dit il a beaucoup plus si vous
voulez venir vérifier mettez des bottes
et venez venez dans les champs donc
l'administration a quand même fait
marche arrière en disant on n pas besoin
des photos géolocalisées on n' pas
besoin des rel c'est intéressant très
intéressant ça donne ça donne la façon
dont on est considéré par
l'administration française est
européenne parce qu'en fait
l'administration agricole française ne
fait que suivre ce que demande
l'administration agricole européenne oui
Marguerite on marche sur la tête là
franchement on infantilise les
agriculteurs on leur
demand sur c'est policiers c'est pas
pareil c'est pas du tout pareil'est
qu'est-ce que Gabriel hatal peut faire
est-ce qu'on peut rayer d'un trait de
plume puisque c'est du réglementaire pas
besoin de légiférer un certain nombre de
de paperas de règles alors oui j'ai un
exemple peut-être encore plus
caricatural peut-être un peu moins moins
extraordinaire mais une une agricultrice
de mon de de Saint-Hélène donc de ma
circonscription me disait que quand elle
a voulu étendre créer monter un petit
bâtiment pour faire de la vente bio
aussi d'ailleurs sur notamment de de la
viande bovine elle m'expliquait qu'il y
avait un document plusieurs documents
d'ailleurs même qu'elle devait mettre
dans le dossier donc qui devait faire
500 ou 600 pages neu fois vous savez
come on demande plusieurs exemplaires
pour pouvoir les répartir à d'autres
administrations ou d'autres unités
administratives et cetera enfin à
l'heure où on peut globalement numériser
si on l' une fois on peut le scanner
enfin bref on peut faire des tas de
choses c'est anecdotique donc elle me
dit qu'elle é la Chalon sur sa à 30 km
du village pour faire faire la queue
dépenser 40 € voilà donc on peut ça peut
paraître anecdotique mais en fait ça
c'est tous les jours donc vous allez
dire mais pourquoi vous découvrez
maintenant c'est vrai on c'est on c'est
peut-être un peu tard néanmoins cet
exemple il est évidemment atterrant donc
oui on peut le faire et il faut qu'on se
fixe je sais pas on prend les les 30
formulaires les plus utilisés on dit
qu'on divise par de leur volume moi je
suis en charge parilleurs de la
simplification sur la vie des
entreprises sur ch de simplification Pr
parlementaire donc oui il faut le faire
il faut piloter très finement
l'administration et c'est une question
aussi c'est important d'état d'esprit il
faut qu'on soit dans une administration
et ça c'est vrai d'ailleurs pas que sur
agriculture qui conseille plus on a plus
le faire contrôle et qui exactement et
qui contrôle
après pror d'accord avec ça c'est du bon
sens je suis viticulteur je je subis les
14 déclarations par an pour le le les
les douan les les dossiers pack avec les
mots de passe qui changent tous les 6
mois tout ça pour toucher moins de 2000
€ de de de subvention donc c'est cet
enfer bureaucratique est imposé aux
agriculteurs monsieur Marguerite semble
le découvrir mais il il est vieux comme
le monde et et il empoisonne la la vie
des agriculteurs donc vous allez vous
retrouver là-dessus sur leou simpication
le le problème c'est c'est c'est c'est
pourquoi en C ans le le le pouvoir en
place n'a pas réussi à avancer sur cette
question et si vous voulez ça peut pas
être la la réponse à ce qui se passe de
très profond et de très grave quand
quand on parle de ces manifestations
agricoles la la réponse à ça ça va pas
être une petite loi de simplifie Simp
donc on en vient pour terminer à la
question européenne si je vous voulez
bien pour conclure ce
débat au désespoir est- que est-ce que
ce n'est pas pour terminer ce débat qui
malheureusement s'achève il y a beaucoup
de sujets dans ce dossier c'est pas
justement l'Europe le meilleur levier
pour agir Grégoire de fournasse mais si
vous voulez l'Europe c'est quand même
les traités de libre échange c'est femme
tout fort qu' avec la feuille de route
de décroissance agricole que que que que
les macronistes ont voté avec les les
les les écologistes l'Europe c'est quand
même une volonté de de de de
décroissance Agricole vous avez un texte
qui est quand même symptomatique c'est
restauration de la nature c'est imposer
le retour à l'état naturel de 20 % des
des terres agricoles quand dans le même
temps on met sur le fronton du ministère
de l'Agriculture l'enjeu de la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est ça
l'injonction contradictoire c'est dire
aux agriculteurs soyez capable de
nourrir la population et dans le même
temps on va vous réduire V TER agricole
on va vous enlever des produits pH sans
alégocier des pays étrangers je pense
particulièrement à l'Amérique du Sud la
réciprocité mais nous sommes perdant
nous sommes perdants dans ce système
totalement ouvert on importe on importe
la moitié des du poulet la moitié des
fruits et légumes 25 % du BF nous sommes
perdants dans dans dans vous vous dites
votez pour moi aux élections européennes
pour faire quoi pour sortir pour faire
quoi fa une inflexion il faut une
inflexion de la politique européenne une
profonde inflex en restant dedans
qu'est-ce que vous répondez REM dans la
caricature de la récupération politique
c'est vra c'est vraiment dommage mais on
est un peu habitué avec le avec le
R
je vous écout pas besoin de hurler
simplement pour dire que la France c'est
opposé au Traité du mercusur point
numéro 1 et qui n'a pas toujours c'est
c'est la réalité point numéro 2 à
l'initiative de la France on a interdit
on a interdit l'importation de viande
avec qui était traité avec des
antibiotiques de croissance ça c'est ça
c'est 2023 c'est récent on a
inter traité donc tout ça c'est
l'initiative de la France je dis pas que
c'est assez et je dis évidemment il faut
aller plus loin mais ce n'est pas vrai
et évidemment les députés du
rassemblement national qui découvrent
brellel on va s'arrêter là peut-être
Emmanuel duc peut-être juste pour pour
apaiser en gu de conclusion c'est le bon
niveau mais il faut que la France pèse
est-ce qu'elle a les marges de manœuvre
l'Europe c'est ce qui a construit la
puissance agricole l'Europe c'est aussi
notre paix alimentaire et ça on doit pas
l'oublier après je crois
qu'effectivement il est temps qu'on se
pose la question j'ai beau être
profondément attaché aux échanges
internationaux je pense qu'il est temps
qu'on découvre que l'alimentation et la
nourriture doivent être extrait des
traités de Liv é change et vraiment
c'est un chemin que j'ai fait et là je
me rends compte que on détruit nos
filières pour importer du pire et ça ça
ne peut pas durer et ben voilà on va
s'arrêter sur cette not jeis vous
laisser débattre parce que c'est
passionnant en dehors de ce studio mais
je voudais qu'on garde un petit peu de
temps pour vous David funkenos merci à
vous merci d'être venu sur LCP dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties prit
noous affranchi vous les voyez ils sont
fin prêts Richard Verly qui va revenir
sur les livraisons d'armes à l'Ukraine
l'Europe est-elle enfin à la hauteur et
puis le philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyot
qui s'interroge sur la politique
nataliste d'Emmanuel Macron à tout à
l'heure et puis Bourbon et presse quel
est le programme à amandagava bien
beaucoup de députés rêvent de devenir
Premier ministre ben la première
ministre elle elle redevient députée
merci à tout à l'heure alors on va
partir
maintenant voyager en Coré dans les
cabinets on va plonger dans la vie
heureuse votre roman David fonkinos chez
galimar l'histoire d'ériic et Amélie
deux camarades de lycée qui se
retrouvent 20 ans plus tard je le disais
à la fois en Asie mais aussi à Paris de
son point de vue le le sien le garçon
puis le point de vue d'Amélie on regarde
ça pour bien comprendre parce que il y a
quand même quelque chose qui se passe en
Corée qui pourrait à nous arrivver c'est
signé Stéphanie des piierre invitation
et interview juste
[Musique]
après si on vous invite David feninos
c'est parce que dans votre dernier livre
vous vous attaquer un sujet sensible et
politique la mort et parce qu'une loi
est en préparation sur la fin de vie
romancier dramaturg et scénariste vous
êtes une machine à bestcellerire depuis
2009 et lapparution de la délicatesse
vendue à plus d'un million d'exemplaires
en 2014 avec votre roman sur la peintre
juive Charlotte Salomon vous ratez de
peu le goncours vous vous consolez avec
celui des lycéens et le prix renaudo
dans la vie heureuse
vous plz un décor très contemporain éic
la quarantaine divorcé intègre un
cabinet ministériel du quinena
d'Emmanuel Macron il pilote les dossiers
de
réindustrialisation lors d'un voyage
d'affair Eric fait une expérience qui va
bouleverser sa vie à sou il pousse la
porte d'un centre qui propose de vivre
un faux enterrement son propre
enterrement votre fiction s'inspire d'un
concept qui existe vraiment
ch première étape pour les volontaires
rédiger une lettre d'adieu à ses proches
merci d'avoir été mes enfants et de
m'avoir donné tant de
bonheur je vous aime
maman la déclaré votre corps est emmené
à
l'hôpital après une fausse cérémonie les
participants s'allongent dans un vrai
cercueil durant plusieurs minutes dans
le noir total
je sens le vent et c'est bon vous savez
ce que je ressens là en ce moment je
veux profiter de tout ça quand j'ai
ouvert les
yeux c'était comme si une seconde chance
m'était
donné cette mort fictive serait un
remède à la
dépression quand les gens font
l'expérience de la mort leur conscience
devient plus
mature ceux qui sont passés par là ne se
suicident jamais
votre roman raconte cet électrochoc pour
un retour vers une vie heureuse et
pourquoi pas vers une fin heureuse alors
David finos doit-on pouvoir décider du
jour de sa
mort le sujet est très très bien j'ai
pas besoin de faire l'adaptation au
cinéma c'était un film c'est vrai que
voir les images c'est c'est extrêmement
parlant c'est fascinant mais une mort
fictive peut vous aider à renaître
vraiment oui je crois mais alors
étonnant c'est que pant le sujet vous
avez vous avez eu un un sursaut de
frayeur et c'est vrai que ça paraît très
particulier ici en France en Occident
voilà c'est vrai que tout simplement
j'ai entendu parler de ce rituel qui est
qui est un véritable phénomène en Corée
du Sud on parle d'un pays voilà bah le
sujet la dit avec beaucoup de taux de de
suicide dépression pression sociale une
société très difficile et il y a un
malide très très fort et cette thérapie
de choc devient un véritable phénomène
voilà ça a été dit le simple fait de
vivre physiquement la mort de s'allonger
dans son CERC CCIL de rédiger quelques
mots pour voilà raconter peut-être les
choses importantes de sa vie ça vous
donne de la vitalité voilà ça vous
permet une des femmes a dit elle parle
d'une seconde vie une renaissance et
donc je pense que tous les gens qui ont
été gravement malades ou qui sont
confrontés comme ça des choses un peu
extrêmes peuvent comprendre oui je l'ai
vécu moi effce que c'est ça qu'il faut
il faut dire tout de même même si ceux
qui vous lisent le le savent bien vous
avez connu une expérience de mort après
une une très grave infection pulmonaire
qui vous a cloué à l'hôpital pendant des
mois vous-même vous êtes partis h vous
l'avez vu cette fameuse lumière tunnel
ou tout àit ce sent quoi mourir quelques
secondes et on remonte moi j'ai été mort
quelques secondes voilà ma mère était
devant moi elle m'a raconté c'est vrai
que j'ai eu l'expérience de de du tunnel
et je suis revenu à la vie et c'est vrai
que ça a changé ma vie d'une manière
miraculeuse parce que après alors que
j'étais pas essu d'un milieu forcément
culturel je me suis mis à lire à écrire
j'étis propulsé vers la sensibilité et
surtout j'ai eu le sentiment d'avoir une
deuxième vie à à ce moment-là une vie où
je suis en capacité non pas non pas
d'être dans la joie en permanence mais
en tout cas d'essayer d'avoir un rapport
plus apaisé aux choses de la vie h après
Charlotte sur la peintre Charlotte
Salomon vous lui rendez hommage en la
citant en exerc de ce livre on devait
même pour aimer plus encore la vie être
mort une fois ben c'est un peu le slogan
de ma vie oui il y a quelque chose de
cette ordre là en tout cas l'idée que
cette étape- là cette étape qui peut
être douloureuse l'expérimentation de la
mort les choses graves qu'on peut vivre
peuvent après nous propuler dans dans
quelque chose oui qui peut nous aider à
aimer qui en tout cas nous permet
d'avoir d'avoir un rapport peut-être
plus léger aussi à à certaines choses
mais moi ça me permet aussi d'interroger
l'idée de bah de changer de vie d'aller
chercher ce qui est important ou pas
dans sa propre vie d'aller questionner
l'essentiel et ça c'est extrêmement
contemporain euh on se rend bien compte
de nombre de personnes autour de nous
qui changent de vie et qui vont aller
interroger c'est d'ailleurs un REM aussi
sur la relation amouruse sur le bon
moment sur l'étincelle qui fait que on
voit l'autre à un moment pourquoi votre
héros qui va pas bien qui est très
mélancolique qui est coupable de la mort
de son père qui a pas la garde de son
fils qui s'engueule avec sa mère
pourquoi il ouvre la porte de Happy
Life cette entreprise en Corée du Sud
qui fait des faux enterrement là où vous
avez raison c'est vrai que c'est aussi
une histoire d'amour il y a au cœur de
cette histoire le rituel coréen mais
c'est une histoire sur 30 ans voilà un
chasser croisé entre un homme et une
femme qui se croise qui se retrouve qui
se rate euh et voilà qui vont finalement
comprendre pourquoi la ville les met en
en permanence l'un face à l'autre lui
c'est vrai que il travaille chez
Décathlon il a 40 ans il est un peu au
bout de sa vie tout le monde lui dit
alors à fond la forme il en peut plus il
est traversé par la mélancolie il a
besoin d'un électrochoc en tout cas
quelque chose qui va le pousser euh à
changer de vie à prendre les bonnes
décisions et c'est vrai que le hasard
avec une succession d'étrangeté qui font
qu'il va se retrouver assez sou face à
cette face à ce rituel et finalement
c'est quelque chose qui l'attendait et
qui était nécessaire pour lui et qui le
propulse à nouveau dans la vie alors
vous l'avez faite cette expérience
vous-même on a retrouvé la photo dans
Paris Match forcément oui alors oui
voilà j'ai fait j'ai fait des photos
dans un dans un
cercueil j'ai bien aimé j'ai bien aimé
parce que pour moi c'est pas du tout
morbide il y a quelque chose justement
voilà qui fait du bien qui permet aussi
de de remettre les choses en place de
faire un bilan sur son propre parcours
et puis peut-être voilà d'appréhender de
manière plus positive on n pas cloué on
vous a pas mis dans le
noir même alors c'est vrai que dans le
rituel vous êtes vraiment il y a le
couvercle alors attention c'est une
thérapie pour vous faire du bien pas
pour vous angoisser hein si ça si vous
le faites Myriam et que vous êtes
effrayé on vous ouvre le couverc on vous
on arrête l'expérience mais mais je
pense quefin dans mon livre le rituel
arrive en France et euh alors il y a
quelques angoisses ici en France mais
j'espère que ça va arriver parce que
vraiment c'est extrêmement positif et ça
fait ça fait du bien alors on a compris
c'est un roman sur l'amour sur le bon
moment on pense à Harry rencontre qui
Harry rencontre sal vous le citez
d'ailleurs ce film formidable c'est un
roman un peu aussi sur la politique
parce que elle est secrétaire elle est
directrice de
cabinet du du secrétaire d'État au
Commerce extérieur alors on croise pas
mal de de monde vous l'aimez ce mondeel
vous aimez les poli oui voilà c'est pour
ça je je voulais être invité sur LCP
donc j'ai rajouté un ver politique dans
mon Liv mais vous serez toujours le
bienven en tout cas ce qui est
intéressant pour moi c'est que on l'a
raconé il y a ce rituel qui peut
paraître un peu loufo extrême mystique
et j'avais besoin de contrebalancer avec
un environnement extrêmement concret
donc la vie professionnelle chez
Decathlon pour lui et puis le
gouvernement pour elle effectivement
commerce extérieur d'un point de vue
basique j'avais besoin qu'il parte à sou
à un moment donné ça c'est certain mais
le monde politique me passionne j'ai la
chance en tant qu'écrivain de bah de
rencontrer très souvent les politiques
de les questionner de pouvoir échanger
avec eux et c'est vrai que je raconte un
petit peu les arcanes et de la de la de
l'ambition et de la désillusion pour
cette femme qui a envie de gravir les
échelons ou oui d'ailleurs on croise
Emmanuel Macron qui vous fait croire
que connais personnellement qui tu tois
tout le monde et Amélie va même jusqu'à
téléphoner à Alexis CER secrétaire
général de de l'élisé il fallait casser
justement cette dimension un peu
mystique avec des figures du réel avec
presque une manière de peindre un un
milieu quitte un peu à à s'en moquer de
façon ironique sais pas si je m'en moque
parce que je je pense que cette cruauté
là on peut la trouver dans Milie
politique et puis dans d'autres milieux
mais ce qui me ce qui me touchait
c'était de voir cette femme aussi avec
avec une ambition extrêmement sincère de
réussite certes mais en tout cas voilà
de vouloir aider son pays de vouloir
travailler à la compagne de d'éventuel
réélection d'Emmanuel Macron et puis euh
voilà au gré d'un reméniment elle ne
elle ne suit pas euh son ministre de
tutelle elle n'est pas intégrée dans la
dans la nouvelle équipe il y a quelque
chose de l'ordre de la ouais de la
violence de d'être délaissé et c'est
c'est quelque chose que même voilà les
acteurs aussi peuvent ressentir par
rapport par rapport au désir de l'autre
ou je vais vous montrer une fleur vous
allez la reconnaître immédiatement cette
fleur elle est rouge elle a des longs
poils est-ce qu'on l' pour l'instant je
me vois moi effectivement alorsonnaissz
oui c'est la fleur
licoris voilà c'est licoris licoris
radiata c'est c'est d'abord le le mot
licorisme me plaisait beaucoup et c'est
vrai que mon personnage va appeler la la
la le le le rituel enfin la version
française du rituel licoris parce que
c'est une fleur qui symbolise le passage
vers l'au-delà voilà il y a il y a tout
un une réflexion mystique aussi autour
de cette fleur et j'aimais bien j'aime
bien travailler sur les symboles h vous
pensez que ce rituel s'il venait en
France il permettrait aussi d'avoir
moins peur de la mort je crois et puis
on voit
bien toute la nouvelle génération avec
les angoisses aussi liées au climat
voilà le malêtre l'incertitude aussi de
toute une nouvelle génération mais vous
me voyez venir il y a un débat
parlementaire sur la fin de vie ouais
complètement et c'est vrai que entre la
question de l'euthanasie le suicide
assisté qu'est-ce que vous vous en
pensez parce que ce rituel aujourd'hui
il permet de renaître mais parfois il
faut pouvoir accepter cette mort
peut-être la mettre en scène peut y
parvenir qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la
loi est-ce qu'il faut il faut je suis
complètement pour et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on avance et qu'on avance vraiment
beaucoup plus loin dans cette loi euh
mais on sent à chaque fois c'est pas la
première fois que ça va revenir encore
au cœur de l'actualité on sent une
crisep pass très très forte ici euh moi
je reviens d'un voyage au Mexique quand
on voit le rapport à la mort on fête les
morts on leur offre des cadeaux on voit
toutes les couleurs autour de la mort
c'est vrai qu'ici c'est c'est
extrêmement difficile euh avec le
vieillissement de la population et des
cas extrêmement difficiles comme ça de
de fin de vie ça me paraî évident qu'il
faut absolument légiférer et avancer ça
a été dit voilà par le par le
gouvernement j'espère vraiment que ça va
être ça va être acté en tout cas on
attend on attend toujours la main
trante et on peut lire la vie heureuse
merci beaucoup David finos c'est à lire
chez galimar comme toujours avec avec
vos romans on va terminer avec les
parties pris de nos affranchis vont vous
faire réagir on accueille nos
chroniqueur tout de
suite
Pierre Henri tavoyot du collège de
philosophie bienvenue à vous et Richard
verli bonne année à tous les deux
d'ailleurs du quotidien suisse bli je
vous ai pas vu depuis 2024 on commence
par Bourbon Express comme chaque soir
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous Elsa mondingava qui nous l'a
raconté bonsoir Elsa bonsoir et bien on
connaissait tous ellisabeth borne
première ministre on va la découvrir
bientôt député la première ministre je
le rappelle elle a démissionné le 8
janvier dernier enfin enfin il a fallu
qu'elle démissionne si vous avez suivi
un peu lors de sa passation elle s'est
dite impatiente de venir siéger ici à
l'Assemblée on le rappelle ellisabeth
borne elle a été élue dans le Calvados
en juin 2022 elle a jamais siégé
puisqu'elle a tout de suite été nommée à
Matignon elle va pouvoir prendre son
siège donc à partir du 9 février
prochain et elle passe donc de Première
ministre à député parmi 567 c'est pas
forcément évident ellisabeth borne qui
revient à l'Assemblée vous pensez que ça
va être facile pour elle vous savez la
politique est une école
d'humilité et voilà on peut-être au
sommum des responsabilités et puis
redevenir simple mortel si j'ose dire
donc je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'elle a probablement tout à fait
intégré alors comment elle le prépare ce
retour ellisabeth borne et bien écoutez
hier elle a rencontré le président du
groupe Renaissance Sylvain Maillard ils
ont préparé son arrivée ils ont parlé
déjà bureau alors évidemment l'ancienne
Première ministre ne va pas siéger
n'importe où ici à l'Assemblée il y a un
bureau qui est déd dit aux anciens
Premier ministre c'est le plus grand du
palais dit-on 30 m²r rendez-vous compte
et puis elle réfléchit à la commission
qu'elle va intégrer il y a un autre
sujet sensible c'est la place qu'elle
occupera dans l'hémicycle on imagine le
plus loin possible des bans de la gauche
h alors c'est pas la première fois que
d'ancien Premier ministre font le chemin
de Matignon à l'Assemblée non c'est même
assez courant on peut penser à Jacques
Chirac ou Laurent fabus plus récemment
Jean-Marc HUD par exemple congédié par
François Hollande après des municipales
raté et bien il fait son retour au
groupe socialiste au palais Bourbon le 6
mai 2014 voilà ce qu'il déclare aux
journalistes venus bien nombreux pour
son retour plus libre sûrement mais avec
le même souhait c'est de contribuer à la
réussite de la France voilà si
ellisabeth band n'a pas d'inspiration
elle pourra s'inspirer des déclarations
de Jean-Marc hot et puis comme on est
sympa on a d'autres conseils pour la
néodéputé par exemple se méfier un peu
elle est attendue de pieds fermes par
les oppositions est-ce qu'on peut
imaginer que vous la chahutiez un peu
enfin qu'elle ait le droit à un petit
comité de l'accueil des oppositions
c'est pas impossible pas impossible
éisabeth que vous ayez quelques quelques
mots d'accueil parce que vu comme vous
avez humilié le le Parlement c'est pas
impossible qu'on vous le rappelle ou la
voilà donc prévenue elle sera pas toute
seule il y aura d'autres ministres pour
l'accompagner ellisabeth borne dans ce
retour oui alors on connaît pas encore
la liste puisquemmanuel Macron et
Gabriel hatal tardent à donner la
composition finale du gouvernement mais
effectivement d'autres ministres vont
rejoindre les bandes de l'hémicycle un
conseil aussi pour eux c'est Stéphane
traver qui nous le donne il sait de quoi
il parle puisqu'il a été député ministre
puis puté quel est le conseil que vous
donnez aux ministres qui vont revenir
faut pas se la raconter vous êtes des
députés comme tout le monde maintenant
ah ben c'est exactement ça l'humilité ça
ne gêne rien et c'est pas parce que vous
avez été ministre que lorsque vous
arrivez à l'Assemblée c'est poussez-vous
de là que je m'y mette et vous allez
voir ce que vous allez voir non c'est il
faut prendre sa place faire sa place
travailler humilité travail les anciens
ministres et l'ancienne Première
ministre sont prévenus merci beaucoup
Elsa Monin Gava Richard l'Europe vous
nous parlez Ukraine et vous parlez ce
soir d'aide militaire Thierry Breton le
commissaire européen
l'affirme livraison d'un million d'obus
à Kiev Emmanuel Macron lui veut produire
plus vite les matériels militaire ça y
est c'est l'économie de guerre pour Kief
enfin oui Thierry Breton a promis que le
million d'obut serait bien livré à
l'Ukraine sans doute d'ici le milieu de
cette année il l'a répété aujourd'hui
même en Pologne où il poursuit sa
tournée des industriels de la défense
alors cette Europe de la défense elle se
met sur le pied de guerre en effet les
industries d'armement sont en train de
redoubler d'effs pour réapprovisionner
les arsenaux des 27 pays membres de
l'Union et pour apporter l'indispensable
soutien militaire à l'Ukraine c'est vrai
en France où l'usine Nexter près de
Bourges promet de sortir deux fois plus
de canon César de ses gênes de
production cette année afin d'en livrer
comme promis 78 à l'Ukraine c'est vrai
en Norvège où l'usine Namo de Ros à 100
km au nord d'Oslo est en train de
doubler sa capacité de production d'obus
et de poudre on peut citer aussi
l'allemand Rin metéal qui construit les
chars léopard 2 A7 la dernière version
du tank le plus utilisé en Europe idem
pour l'anglais BAE système tous ces
industriels n'ont qu'un chiffre sur leur
carnet de commande qui sont pleins 155
pourquoi 155 mm c'est le calibre des
fameux obus tirés par les canons des
forces de l'OTAN mais donc on ne pourra
plus dire trop peu trop tard et ben pas
tout à fait car trois obstacles
demeurent en face face à une Russie qui
elle est passée en économie de guerre en
accordant la priorité aux producteurs de
munitions et de canon sur toute autre
production industrielle alors le premier
obstacle pour les Européens c'est le
volume il ne faut pas seulement aider
Kief il faut aussi renouveler le
matériel des armées européennes pour
palier à toute vulnérabilité stratégique
dans cette période de tension le
Danemark par exemple n'a toujours pas
reçu la quinzaine de canon César qu'il
avait commandé payés et qui ont été
livrés à l'Ukraine où 49 de ces canons
autoportés sont opérationnel le deuxième
obstacle c'est l'argent car il faut les
payer les industriels or qui dit achat
européen pour l'Ukraine dit dépenses
supplémentaire c'est l'argument de
Victor Orban le Premier ministre
hongrois proche de Vladimir Poutine et
de son collègue slovaque Robert fitzo
tous deux répètent avant le prochain
sommet européen du 1er février que les
achats d'armes pour l'Ukraine ne doivent
pas être financés sur le budget de
l'Union européenne et le troisème
obstacle enfin c'est la concurrence et
il faut le rappeler concurrence entre
les industriels qui vont se disputer les
commandes et les usines mais aussi
concurrence entre fabricants européens
et tous ceux qui ont du matériel
disponible à vendre sur étagère alors
c'est le cas des États-Unis mais aussi
des Sud-Coréens la Pologne pour mémoire
a acheté à sou un millier de chars bref
oui l'économie de guerre européenne est
en marche mais dans ce type de
production industrielle c'est très
différent car cette souveraineté là
celle des armes elle reste de très loin
la plus difficile à partager ouais on va
bientôt fêter c'est pas le bon mot
célébrer je sais pas je sais pas quel
mot dire les deux
an de la guerre en Ukraine et l'invasion
russe on peut encore la gagner vous
pensez moi je pense que ça va être
compliqué j'étais en Ukraine moi j'ai
monté un spectacle j'étais tout le mois
de juillet à viive ce la vraie
inquiétude c'est la potentielle élection
Donald Trump voilà dans quelques mois
qui va peut-être lâcher effectivement
l'Ukraine et ça ça sera à mon avis le
moment de bascule ch allez vous allez
réagir à cette chronique j'en suis sûr
Pierre-Henri vous vous êtes intéressé à
la politique nataliste d'Emmanuel Macron
on sait qu'elle est en baisse une baisse
historique le président veut la relancer
d'autres personnes sont moins d'accord
oui c'est le cas de Sandrine rousseo
dont on a parlé tout à l'heure qui avec
son esprit de contradiction qui le
caractérise cite dit la chose suivante
la baisse de la natalité est au
contraire rassurante pas du tout
angoissante et elle justifie son propos
de deux manières d'une part en tant que
féministe je la cite à nouveau les
utérus des femmes ne sont pas une
affaire d'état chaque femme est libre de
choisir de faire des des enfants ou pas
bon personne n'obligeait dans les
mesures prises mais je rappelle une
petite contradiction avec un propos
qu'elle a tenu c'est elle dit
constamment le privé et politique ce
qu'elle semble dénoncer ici bon passons
le second argument lui est beaucoup plus
cohérent consiste à dire que en tant
qu'économiste dit-elle elle considère
que si on a une politique de
décroissance c'est B qu' est moindre en
France c'est une très bonne nouvelle
alors en revanche c'est pas du tout la
même ligne côté président d'ailleurs
même David lissnard aujourd'hui est sur
la même ligne il faut relancer la
natalité oui le débat est ancien sur la
politique nataliste en France mais il
néglige souvent ce débat une question
toute simple que les philosophes adorent
se poser dans l'histoire qui est la
question pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait des
enfants alors on peut faire l'inventaire
rapide de de des réponses principales
qui sont apportées d' une réponse qui
est une réponse biologique qui défendu
par les philosophes qui consiste à dire
qu'en fait on n' pas le choix et que
c'est en quelque sorte la nature qui se
sert de nos pulsions sexuelles et de nos
passions amoureuses pour au au fond euh
faire perdurer l'espèce hm hm deuxème
argumentation possible plus que culturel
qui consiste à dire qu'au fond si nous
faisons des enfants c'est pour essayer
de neutraliser la peur de la mort on en
parlait la peur de la mort pourquoi
parce que grâce aux enfants qui nous
ressemblent argument d'Aristote souvent
c'est bien il y a quelque chose de nous
qui va rester des souvenirs des des
voilà un peu de de une terre un nom un
héritage c'est un at d'immortalité puis
y a une troisième réponse qui est plus
spirituelle et qui vient notamment du
christianisme le christianisme a cette
idée tout à fait importante que les
enfants nous sauvent un enfant nous
sauve et l'idée que le Dieu
tout-puissant c'est ça la spécificité et
bien c'est manifesté aux hommes parce
qu'il y a de plus fragile de plus
impuissant de plus démuni et que cet
enfant qui nous sauve en fait va sauver
l'humanité alors on peut avoir une
version laïque de cette affaire avec
Rousseau mais Jean-Jacques hein
pasrine Jean-Jacques Rousseau qui dit la
chose suivante au fond le petit être
démuni qui crie quand il vient de naître
c'est un appel à l'aide c'est une
vulnérabilité et c'est lui qui force
l'humanité à se se moraliser c'estàd à
se décentrer de son égoïsme naturel et
cette vulnéabilité comme un appel et
c'est ça qui moralise l'humanité c'est
ça qui nous fait grandir au fond c'est
une idée très profonde c'est en faisant
grandir les autres qu'on grandit
soi-même et qu'on devient au fond une
grande personne donc les enfants ça sert
pas simplement à l'espèce
ou mais ça nous élève é et cette
dimension là vous trouvez qu'elle est en
perte de vitesse pas pas généralement il
y a encore des enfants qui naissent je
crois donc ça existe aussi mais c'est
vrai qu'elle est concurrencé auourd de
manière assez rugueuse par à la fois
l'individualiste c'est-à-dire le le côté
développement personnel enfant si je
veux un enfant si je veux puis par le
côté aussi dé croissantistes en fait on
considère parfois que l'enfant c'est un
un obstacle à la libération de la femme
à la vie épanouie du couple au
développement personnel c'est aussi un
obstacle évidemment au salut de la
planète qui prime le salut de l'humanité
voilà au fond c'est ça l'idée vous
grandir on pourrait dire ça aujourd'hui
est un peu devenu suspect et parfois
même certains ou certaines préfèrent
être
déconstruite une petite réaction non
mais j'ai vu qu'il y avait une très très
grande tendance voilà à ces coupes qui
ne font pas d'enfant qui le revendiquent
et donc voilà je pense que c'est
important de contrecarrer aussi voilà
chacun fait comme il veut mais voilà il
y a de doit rester une liberté mais mais
la politique nataliste c'est un grand
classique hein quel que soit les bord
politique faire des enfants et produire
en même temps beaucoup d'obus et de
matériel d'armement dans l'histoire
pardonnez-moi ça n'a jamais vraiment
porté chance ouais
la note pessimiste on s'arrête là merci
beaucoup David fonkinos lisez la vie
heureuse chez galimar avec cette
histoire à peine croyal de faux
enterrements de faux funérailles pour se
réinventer et se donner une seconde
chance vous avez choisi votre épitaap
déjà vous non mais je vais revenir vous
voir je vais réfléchir quand vous voulez
allez on a le droit de avoir encore
l'idée on se laisse du temps merci merci
à vous c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d' l'avoir suivi soirée
documentaire qui commence à présent avec
Jean-Pierre
à
[Musique]
demain